hi we're happy that we've got blue skies
this morning for the most part a few
high thin sears clouds out there clouds
not sure if you like the humidity we're
stuck with that for sure temperatures
mostly in the kind of a mix now 70s and
80s just updated the numbers nellis is
down to 79 so sunrise mountain and
henderson same for mountains edge seven
hills it seems to be very common number
this morning mid 70s out there at red
rock 62 at kyle canyon 82 in mesquite
down below 80 in boulder city just
barely with mid 70s in indian springs
you had a lot of rain up there yesterday
over half an inch 76 in perum 77 in
sandy valley had some good rain in
southern clark county again yesterday
big thunderstorms 91 in laughlin 90 out
at death valley and again just a
reminder that they've got a lot of roads
closed especially highway 190 out there
in death valley where they've had
so much rain over the last several days
especially over the weekend check out
these pictures this car is just over the
wheel wells where they've had ru mud
rocks debris just
overcoming vehicles out there and just
washed off the roads from very heavy
rains from big thunderstorms over the
weekend so a lot of road closures
impassable roads and areas especially
where they don't have good cement roads
and highways asphalt highways so please
if you're out in rural areas you may run
into some road closures a lot of washes
that were running high with rain water
and flooding over the weekend big
thunderstorms as you can see flaring up
kind of all around us yesterday
we're still not out of the woods yet
there's a lot of tropical moisture from
tropical storm frank that's feeding into
the monsoon moisture but really the
chances for flooding today will be like
over into inyo county and into central
south central nevada for the valley we
still stand a chance of thunderstorms
today but not looking for widespread
flooding just isolated thunderstorms
lots of heat through the middle of the
country and still hot up in the
northwest but it's shifting more inland
and they do have red flag warnings over
the northern rockies today our best
chance of thunderstorms comes in the
mountains 72 for the hype at mount
charleston almost 100 degrees for the
valley and this is about a 20 percent
chance of afternoon and evening
thunderstorms a thinner chance tomorrow
we're talking about 10 look the temps go
up to the low triple digits but boy that
surge returns thursday late friday into
the weekend we're still looking at about
a 30 to 40 percent chance of
thunderstorms so we're not done yet with
monsoon season very healthy still for
this first week of august